welcome sorry welcome to this video
playing a whole chain okay it seems i
played him once before and I one yep so
the one hundred percent score to have to
try to keep searching for don't think
that's a very common move here but ok
it's not that it is some Oh interesting
it just gives me the bishop an honor on
a silver plate let's aim I'm going to
take it and black is losing some time
it's kind of a WoW h5
hmm
okay I took me a moment but I had to
take in this kind of thing so um yeah
okay just wants to play I don't know
what exactly trying to irritate me with
with strange moves but this is not going
to work I don't think so so what is he
doing against this now asking this rook
a very very serious question look a 8
Queen B 7 and Wow let's not go into
let's not go into work yeah Black is
just losing losing this rook now or I
don't know can you somehow only lose a
piece I don't even see that I think it's
a whole rook black resigned yeah okay it
was a quick one yeah Bishop g4 I'm not
sure about if I mean normally black
place are the b5 Bishop f5 or g6 in this
position Bishop f5 is maybe the most
popular move nowadays longest cards has
played this a couple of times but be
five is the traditional move this is
what I played mostly in this position
when I was still playing this is black
there's also a six by the way also not
bad yeah Bishop g4 has the the problem I
mean after queen bee three has to do
this bouquet seven and now he's getting
hit by 95 which is not the case when the
bishop is on f5 and yeah here black has
to move the bishop yeah nope not just
giving it up is it's just handing over a
pretty substantial advantage to white I
think he has to move it somewhere to e6
or whatever
I mean here this is just good for white
I just okay actually this is even
stronger yeah this is this is even
stronger and when I played yeah this is
almost losing for black actually it's
very varied it's very very difficult it
looks a it doesn't look as so bad at
first but I'm threatening h5 winning
this Bishop and he has to play something
like this to to not lose it and after
which i'm going to take and then
attacking me on this square this is
actually not defendable yes something
like that is a disaster you know i like
here can also just a tech this and that
was even stronger okay here i played a
plate quickly he had aged five is so
yeah you cannot afford this kind of
luxuries him having the rukon a seven at
age five played and so on yeah okay i
tried before trying to punish him which
not sure if it's the best but my idea
was that if he takes Knight eggs he
cannot take here because of thought f3
actually maybe I'm wrong I thought f3
would be good with this this idea coming
yeah but it's interesting yeah I have
three it's f3 is actually not
threatening that much yeah okay if he
goes back and I'm winning it's nice but
I'm sorry I actually didn't really
realize that I don't threaten this night
I mean I do but he can take me for so
this isn't so clear you can just play
any move and asked me what my next move
is okay and that means that if or wasn't
really the best probably I can I can of
course just play castles or something I
have three any any normal move okay but
he went here and after that he is just
lost funny funny game yeah and it does
mean though and this is lesson learned
for me if this is happening again that
here I actually shouldn't take him in
this kind of am I probably you never get
the position again but you here white
should should play this this thing and
really get a huge advantage it's much
better than what I played okay thanks
for watching